und jetzt das heute journal
mit kaiser richter und christian sievers
guten abend hinein ostersonntag in einem
land das nach der richtigen strategie
sucht das gerade merkt wie sture
regelungen an ihre grenzen stoßen im
kampf gegen ein virus das sich an keine
regeln hält die wir nicht weiterkommen
mit
das haben wir doch noch nie so gemacht
und wo kommen wir denn da hin
mit der draußen nur kännchen mentalität
weil jetzt flexibilität nötig wäre
pragmatismus solidarität und vertrauen
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat heute
seine zurückhaltung aufgegeben und sich
dafür stark gemacht allen geimpften ihre
alten freiheiten zurückzugeben
er stützt sich dabei auf eine
einschätzung des robert koch instituts
es soll so etwas sein wie die spanische
botschaft der hoffnung susanne freitag
und dominik löschmeister berichten
impfen rund um die uhr seit heute geht
das in saarländischen lebach im ersten
24 stunden im zentrum in deutschland
betrieben von der bundeswehr bis zu 1000
impfungen pro tag können sie hier
verabreichen
wir müssen im schichtdienst arbeiten das
heißt wir brauchen viel zusätzliches
personal das natürlich auch von woanders
abgezogen werden muss aber auch für die
bundeswehr gilt wir wollen zur
normalität zurück und das geht am besten
wenn möglichst viele menschen wirklich
ne geimpft werden können schnelles
impfen das ziel nicht nur im saarland
geimpfte sollen nach plänen des
bundesgesundheitsministers bald
freiheiten zurückbekommen spahn sagte
der bild am sonntag wer vollständig
geimpft ist kann in zukunft wie jemand
behandelt werden der negativ getestet
ist
geimpfte könnten ohne test zum beispiel
ins geschäft nach auslandsreisen
bestünde keine quarantäne pflicht
grundsätzlich ist es richtig dass
geimpften mehr freiheiten wieder
eingeräumt werden müssen weil es sich
jetzt gezeigt hat dass die impfung nicht
nur vor schwerer krankheit schützt
sondern in der regel auch vor ansteckung
und vor der ansteckung die so stark
verlaufen dass man andere infizieren
kann das ist nicht immer der fall aber
meistens konsument sind bestimmte
freiheiten auf jeden fall wieder möglich
grundlage ist einen
die auswertung des robert-koch-instituts
so ist das risiko einer virus
übertragung durch vollständig geimpft ab
dem 15
tag geringer als bei einem infizierten
mit falsch negativen schnelltest ohne
symptome
geimpfte würden zudem wahrscheinlich bei
der verbreitung keine wesentliche rolle
mehr spielen so das lka mehr freiheiten
für geimpfte die bundesländer müssten
das umsetzen
selbstverständlich wird irgendwann es
wichtig sein dass man personen die sich
impfen lassen auch zugesteht sich ihre
grundrechte ihre freiheiten zu nehmen
aber solange wir nicht allen einen impf
angebot gemacht haben halte ich es für
schwierig hier menschen die geimpften zu
priorisieren über zwölf prozent der
deutschen sind bisher mindestens einmal
geimpft mehr als zehn millionen menschen
4,3 millionen haben bereits die zweite
impfung erhalten vollständig geimpfte
hätten ein recht auf freiheiten sagen
experten
letztere müssen dann eben auch von ihren
freiheiten wieder gebrauch machen können
diese unterteilung ist misslich sie kann
auch für unmut sorgen nur
verfassungsrechtlich ändert das nichts
daran dass sich die
freiheitsbeschränkung bei den geimpften
nicht mehr rechtfertigen lässt
bislang sind nur gut fünf prozent der
deutschen vollständig geimpft ihre zahl
dürfte in den kommenden wochen und
monaten aber deutlich steigen und damit
auch der druck nach rückgabe von
freiheitsrechten der papst wirkte heute
bedrückt auch wenn er mut machen wollte
den segen urbi et orbi muss er im
petersdom herr teilen vor wenigen
gläubigen stadt vor zigtausenden auf dem
petersplatz ein fest der kleinen gesten
battis ich finde es schön dass bewusst
meine tempel zum zweiten mal schon
feiern die christen ostern in der
pandemie und suchen kraft in der
botschaft der auferstehung aus hamburg
berichtet martin neeson der glaube
stärker als die angst in den hamburger
michel kamen heute rund 150 gläubige
trotz hoher inzidenz zahlen und appellen
aus politik und kirchen verbänden auf
präsenz gottesdienste zu verzichten
die haben hier ganz tolle hygiene
maßnahmen getroffen es ist eine schwere
zeit und es gibt uns einfach trost und
zuversicht
eine gute predigt zu hören am
ostersonntag dass das einfach schön gott
überwindet den tod das sei die
osterbotschaft so der michel hauptpastor
und gerade jetzt eben wichtiger denn je
es sind wenige leute die kommen aber es
sind eben menschen die kommen denen
gerade der präsentesten so wichtig ist
wie ein lebensmittel und menschen gehen
auch einkaufen in dieser zeit setzen
sich einem markt aus setzen sich einem
lebensmittelladen aussetzen sich auch
möglicherweise den öffentlichen
nahverkehr aus und auch dem verkehr auf
den straßen die auferstehungsgemeinde
hamburg lohbrügge hat schon vor tagen
anders entschieden und an den rein
digitalen gottesdienst vorbereitet für
uns ist das die einzig vernünftige
entscheidung zum wohle aller als wir
wollen alle dass die pandemie so schnell
wie möglich endet und das ist quasi
unser beitrag unserer verzicht dafür
dass das möglichst schnell vorbeigeht
im ringen der kirchen um den richtigen
umgang mit dem zweiten ostern in der
pandemie haben sie in rostock einen
kompromiss gewählt präsenz jahr aber
unter freiem himmel in der gemeinde
stattfindet und gemeinde heißt eben auch
sich zusammenzufinden und daneben auch
unter solchen umständen gemeinsam zu
feiern und das ist ja ganz gut geglückt
frauen schönes erlebnis das so draußen
zu erleben mit der kirche mal von außen
auch in katholischen kirchen wie im
limburger dom wurden gottesdienste mit
gläubigen gefeiert damit das höchste
fest der christenheit kraft spende so
der bischof des bistums limburg und
vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz die nähe des
auferstandenen herrn die wir in dieser
feier spüren durften die trage sie
gerade durch diese krisenzeit hindurch
wo wir uns nicht so treffen können wie
wir es gerne wünschen wo wir aushalten
müssen in den beschränkungen die uns
auferlegt sind damit kein noch größerer
schaden entsteht schaden wollten sie
auch im hamburger michel vermeiden und
so wurde das abendmahl möglichst corona
konform geteilt mit maske und hinter
plexiglas
die kirchen in deutschland zu ostern
komplett dicht zu machen wie es die
kanzlerin wollte das hatten beide großen
konfessionen diesmal abgelehnt die
menschen bräuchten licht in der
dunkelheit und damit sind wir auch schon
in der politik keine server bis
pfingsten will die union ja über die
kanzlerkandidatur entscheiden nun drängt
bundesinnenminister seehofer auf eine
rasche klärung dass die wichtigsten
fragen noch offen sind bekomme der union
ganz offensichtlich nicht sagte er der
welt am sonntag die schlechten
umfragewerte seien ein alarmzeichen
als aussichtsreichste kandidaten gelten
csu-chef söder und nrw-ministerpräsident
laschet mit blick auf die korona
pandemie plädierte seehofer für ein
stärkeres eingreifen des bundes ein
entsprechendes gesetz könne binnen
kürzester zeit verabschiedet werden
ähnlich äußerte sich bayerns
ministerpräsident müller in der bild am
sonntag
es brauche einen einheitlichen
bundesweiten pandemie plan
außerdem sei zu überlegen ob ein
erneuter kurzer aber dafür
konsequenterer lockdown nicht besser sei
als ein so wörtlich halbherziges und
dafür endloses corona konzept die
bundesregierung hat nun auch den
niederlande zum hoch incidents gebiet
erklärt das bedeutet schärfere regeln
für einreisende ab dienstag dürfen sie
nur mit einem negativen corona test die
grenze passieren
die niederlande sind bereits das vierte
nachbarland das als hoch inzidenz gebiet
gilt zuvor waren schon polen tschechien
und frankreich hochgestuft worden
der französische bezirk modell gilt
außerdem als virusvarianten gebiet nach
den querdenken demonstrationen in
stuttgart gibt es heute viel kritik
nicht nur an den teilnehmern sondern
auch an politikern und polizei
obwohl die meisten der 15.000
demonstranten weder masken trugen noch
abstand hielten waren die beamten kaum
eingeschritten
die deutsche polizei gewerkschaft wirft
der stadtverwaltung vor die kundgebungen
erlaubt und damit der polizei so
wörtlich den mist vor die füße gekippt
zu haben
[Musik]
mafia raus haben sie gerufen im letzten
sommer zehntausende menschen monate lang
auf den straßen von bulgarien gegen
machtmissbrauch vetternwirtschaft und
korruption laut transparency
international gibt es kein land in der
europäischen union das korrupter wäre
als bulgarien
heute ist dort parlamentswahl es wäre
die chance etwas zu ändern am
herrschaftssystem des bojko borisov mit
dem der ministerpräsident seit gut einem
jahrzehnt sein land steuert das ärmste
der eu mit hohen infektionszahlen und
niedrige impfquote britta elbert
berichtet für seine schöne lage kennt
man willi kotor niveau in bulgarien für
die alten gassen und die stadtgalerie
doch die steht für den
oppositionskandidaten carlo janka fair
für korruption dreimal mehr als den
marktpreis zahlte die öffentliche hand
für die fenster die ausschreibung war
gezinkt die justiz schaut weg das hat
system meint er
der fisch stinkt vom kopf her
die regierung ist verantwortlich für all
das wie ausschreibungen gemacht werden
und wie auf betrug untersucht wird sie
tun es nicht
zu tausenden protestierten im letzten
jahr bulgaren gegen schwache justiz
gegen die regierung und ihre skandale
ein minister saniert sich sein
ferienhaus mit eu fonds eine andere
empfiehlt über betrug mit eu-mitteln zu
schweigen
sonst so sagt sie streicht uns die eu
womöglich noch das geld und
regierungschef borisov wird schlafend so
fotografiert die geldbündel sein
untergeschoben sagt er
bei den oft regierungs abhängigen medien
kommt er damit durch bulgarien ist
schlusslicht im korruptions und
pressefreiheit ranking doch borisov sagt
medien sind bei uns so frei dass man es
kaum mit anderen ländern vergleichen
kann
es wurde schlimmer in paris of some zeit
meint die anti korruptionsexperten
mangelnde pressefreiheit seien nur ein
anzeichen dafür
die pandemie drängt das in den
hintergrund die bulgaren durchleben eine
harte dritte welle haben einer der
höchsten todesraten der eu trotzdem hat
die regierung zuletzt die maßnahmen
sogar gelockert angst vor ansteckung
verschrecke wähler meinen analysten
vielleicht sogar gewollt
die zahl der infektionen stieg und
trotzdem hat die regierung restaurants
und cafés geöffnet das war leichtsinnig
sie hat es zugelassen dass deshalb die
zahl der wähler sinkt dank ihrer treue
stammwählerschaft können sie deshalb
gewinnen
das ärmste land der eu bild mitten in
der pandemie armut und ungerechtigkeit
treten da in den hintergrund es ist
keine zeit der wechselstimmung
speziell in der hauptstadt sofia kann
man viele junge und gut gebildete
bulgarinnen und bulgaren treffen die ihr
land ändern wollen von grund auf und von
einer liberalen weltoffenen demokratie
träumen die ohne schmiergeld
funktioniert nach den ersten prognosen
heute abend liegt die partei des
amtierenden premierministers wieder vorn
aber offenbar mit verlusten die
regierungsbildung wird kompliziert und
jetzt in dieser sendung noch mal mit dem
blick auf eine nicht immer sportlichen
fußballtag denn in der bundesliga begann
das berliner derby mit einem feuer
ausgelöst durch pyrotechnik es konnte
aber schnell gelöscht werden
das spiel ergab dann ein unentschieden
gastgeber union kamen gegen die härter
nicht über ein 1 1 hinaus so feierte der
vfb stuttgart gegen bremen gewonnen mit
10 der treffer war ein eigentor
beim dfb pokal der frauen hat vfl
wolfsburg das finale erreicht die frauen
gewannen gegen den fc bayern mit 2 zu 0
und beendeten damit die serie der
münchnerinnen alexandra popp brachte
wolfsburg in der 13 minute in führung
in der nachspielzeit der ersten hälfte
folgte das 2 0 durch aber hallo im
finale treffen die wolfsburgerinnen am
30 mai auf eintracht frankfurt
das oster finale wird ungemütlich hier
ist das wetter nur im süden bleibt es
morgens länger freundlich ansonsten
kommt von norden her regen auf später
gibt es bei wechselnder bewölkung schnee
und graupelschauer sowie kurze gewitter
bei vier bis 14 grad weht ein starker
westlicher wind mit schweren sturmböen
danach bleibt es dann sehr wechselhaft
mit etwas sonne und vielen schnee schnee
regen und graupelschauern sowie
kräftigem wind dabei wird es deutlich
kälter
ungemütlich fernseh wetter halt morgen
an dieser stelle gundula gause und claus
kleber vom gesamten heute-journal team
ein frohes osterfest und einen schönen
abend noch
[Musik]